hey what is up guys I'm qHD here and I
just tweeted this so asking people to
get their questions in for the next ask
mkbhd video now I'm going to go through
the questions that you guys are asking
and hopefully we get some good ones
let's just get right into it alright so
first question is CES 2016 wants to know
I'm guessing if I'm going to be there I
do plan on being there I've gone to a
bunch of CES is in a row hopefully again
they accept YouTube channels as press or
at least allow us to go and maybe we'll
have a meet-up or we'll do something
similar to what we did last time which
was a lot of fun a what phone are you
using at the moment and the responses is
the Samsung Galaxy s6 edge he's right
it's a black version even though it's
kind of blue I have a black carbon fiber
dbrand skin on the back and I'm using
that material theme that I did a video
about before the battery life is still
abysmal
but I really like the display and a
camera so this is my daily right now
happy or annoyed DeAndre is back in LA
as a Clippers fan I'm happy I can
understand that what he did could have
been like handled better than the way he
handled it and maybe if you guys don't
know what I'm talking about I'll leave a
link below to that situation it was kind
of funny with all the emojis and
everything like that but I'm happy he's
back and this actually makes us a really
good team this year when are you doing
another collab with the verge I so I
guess when we have another good idea to
make a collaboration the idea of
collaborating is to make a video that
wouldn't be possible with either of us
by ourselves the last thing we did was
that dream smartphone video where we
collaborated and I think if we have
another good idea maybe in the comments
section below we can make that happen
on another awesome video what's been the
best iPhone so far in your opinion I'm
just screenshot in these as I get to
them the best iPhone should be the
latest one every time right so the
iPhone six-plus I use the six plus a lot
more than I use the six but it's always
funny when you see the review saying
this is the best iPhone yet well of
course it is it's the newest one the
last one came out a year ago anyway I
like the iPhone 6 plus what's your take
on the expected camera quality of the
oneplus 2 hype favorite color on the
Tesla Model S I'm actually torn
there's a couple actually so there's a
red which is obviously like please pull
me over and arrest me bright red and
then there's the gray the black is like
a third choice for me I think I'll
definitely like the black rims I don't
know why more people don't get the black
rims but I'm torn between the red and
the gray on a Tesla I think they both
look great though when did you start
making YouTube videos I started making
videos in 2009 my first tech video that
I ever uploaded was uploaded on January
1st 2009 and obviously that video if you
didn't know that we were the same person
you might not think that that video was
uploaded by the same person who's making
this video but anyway yeah that's when
it all started would you use an iPhone
as a daily driver if it ran stock
Android uh I don't actually know I don't
think so because the honestly the it
doesn't have the best camera on a phone
anymore and it doesn't have the best
screen anymore a lot of the things that
people really use the iPhone 4 or iOS
and it's build quality and I really like
the build of this phone and some others
as well so I guess it would be nice if
we could get like an iPhone six-plus
running sort of stock Android I guess
more specifically but I don't know if
I'd use that how's your ultimate team
doing my ultimate team so if you don't
if you aren't familiar with ultimate
frisbee it's kind of confusing because
there's a bunch of different seasons
does the pro season that's over but
there's also the college season and
there's a club season I'm in the middle
of the Club season right now we have a
tournament this weekend and that will
pretty much determine how our season
starts off hopefully really well will
there be an rx100 marked for review yes
it's like right over there I plan on
shooting some vlog style stuff with it
since I know that's a reason why a lot
of people are injured in this camera but
also testing the photo capabilities as
well so far I'm liking it a lot though
as I liked the rx100 mark 3 would you
rather have a 16 K display on your
desktop or an 8k display on your phone
I'm gonna go with a 16 K display on my
desktop because that's going to be a
much larger surface area and that kind
of needs that many pixels my phone may
be a 4k display still more than I need
but 8k would be overkill not that either
of these isn't overkill but I'd love to
see 16 K on my desktop status of the
mkbhd website so I'm glad people are
still interested in it because it's been
like quiet about that for so long if you
ask me six months ago the answer would
have been
I'm working on it but now the answer is
we are working on it and we're almost
done well you will you do $1,000 PC
build I know I won't but I'm doing a
video about a PC already but there's
this really great channel that's about
to hit a million subscribers and it's
already done a really great thousand
dollar PC build so if we could get that
channel to a million subscribers like
today you should totally click the
little I and subscribe to that channel
and make it happen and also watch that
video when is the next periscope session
I've been periscoping a little more
recently uh I guess I'll do another one
soon like I don't really plan them
typically they're more spontaneous but
that sort of live show stuff is really
fun so if you aren't already following
me on periscope it's the same as my
Twitter name mkbhd how do people react
when they see you shooting outside
usually oh I mean usually they don't
react but they usually kind of just like
give a little side eye like what is that
what is that guy doing that tripod over
there and why is that phone in a tree do
you think Facebook videos will overtake
YouTube will ever overtake YouTube uh
maybe ever but I don't think it's going
to happen anytime soon look the question
it really to ask yourself is if you're
going to search for a video online you
want to find a video where are you going
to go you're going to go to youtube and
search for word there you're not going
to go to Facebook to search for a video
and until that answer changes
I don't think Facebook video is going to
overtake it anytime soon not to mention
on the blown up view counts thanks to
autoplay but that's not a story how was
the Jurassic Park movie so I did see
Jurassic world if you guys haven't seen
it you should well I mean it's not the
best movie ever but it's really
entertaining to watch which is really
what matters to me when talking about a
movie what are your most have lenses for
YouTube okay I tend to recommend this
because it's expensive but the Sigma 18
to 35 is a zoom lens with all the pros
of a prime lens so it's a fast sharp
wide-angle to mid angle mid-range zoom
it's awesome you should check it out
I'll leave a link below I use it all the
time I'm switching more to Prime's now
but I can't stop using the Sigma what
number did you wear for the New York
Rumble okay so for any old
the Frisbee team I've ever played for
I've worn the number 82 except for my
senior year of high school where for
some reason we didn't get to pick the
numbers I guess because of the way the
jerseys were ordered so I got number six
which is eight minus two do you want a
hound beta invite code actually I have
hound I've used it I started using it a
lot more so for those of you don't know
hound is a voice search app that is
built by the people who made sound hound
and it's really good at a lot of things
that Google now and Siri and Cortana
aren't good at like very specific things
looks like the WolframAlpha voice search
let me give you an example here what is
the monthly payment of a five hundred
thousand dollar mortgage with a 10% down
payment and a four and a half percent
interest rate over 30 years your monthly
mortgage payment is two thousand two
hundred eighty dollars and eight cents
all right right I'm gonna call there
thank you for watching this video and
thank you for submitting your questions
all of you guys who tweeted at me if you
have other questions you want to ask
feel free to leave it in the comments
section below or get at me on Twitter
and yeah that's basically it
so thanks for watching talk to you guys
in the next one peace